i remember having a moment very early in
the research for the book i went to
interview a guy called professor roy
baumeister who's at the university of
queensland in australia
and he's the leading expert in the world
on willpower he wrote a book called
willpower i'm sure everyone's heard of
the marshmallow test he's the guy who
invented that so i go to interview him
and i said you know i'm thinking of
writing a book about why people have got
attention problems trying to figure it
out and he said oh
it's really interesting you say that
because i just find myself these days
just playing games on my phone all the
time i just find you know my own
attention isn't very good i'll say
there's like wait didn't you write a
book called willpower i was like aren't
you the strongest willed person in the
world
literally all the scientific evidence
about willpower but if you're in an
environment that invades you you're not
going to be able you can defend yourself
to some degree and i realize the shift
in consciousness i think we have to make
on this issue and there's a shift in
consciousness on the other 11 issues as
well but on this issue
if you can't focus if you can't pay
attention
it's not your fault there's nothing
wrong with you there's not something
wrong with your children
we are not medieval peasants begging at
the court of king zuckerberg for a few
little crumbs of attention from his
table we are the free citizens of
democracies and we own our own minds and
we can reclaim them from the forces that
are systematically degrading them if we
want to but we have to understand this
as a systemic problem that requires
systemic solutions as well as to some
degree an individual problem that we
have to deal with individually we have
to do both
[Music]
this week on forward the author of
stolen focus why you can't pay attention
and how you can think more deeply johan
hari love this book love this author
this week on forward
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast the author of stolen focus why
you can't pay attention and how you can
think more deeply which we all want to
do johan hari welcome johan
andrew i'm so happy to be with you
especially because you make a cameo
appearance in this book so no slightly
surreal and dreamlike that i'm talking
to you so i'm very happy and i've
applied your work for a long time so i'm
really especially the work you've done
on ubi which also appears in this book
and appeared in my last book so i'm very
very excited to talk to you
well you're a bit of a futurist my
friend but in this case you're a
present-ist in the sense that you're
arguing about a problem that i think
most people
feel very significantly which is that
our attention is eroding we're kind of
losing our minds
and i have turned on the news in the
last five years now you're totally right
you're totally right yeah well the media
landscape is one thing but what i love
about this book is that you think much
more deeply where you have 12 causes as
to why our attention is collapsing but
but first let's describe the problem a
bit and you share some deeply personal
stories about yourself people in your
family like we all have these stories
heck might as well i mean i i will
share share my own version of this and
it's very tough for me johann because
in my case i'm something of
a public figure trying to get things
done so i can convince myself that
twitter is my job
or
or that social social media is like oh
like i'm really doing something
important if i
uh like post this right now
um so i'll tell you
my personal nightmare which i live many
days unfortunately
which is i'm a parent like you are
and
my
nine-year-old and six-year-old first
themselves are addicted to screens but
worse yet when i'm around them i often
wander off and check my phone
instead of focusing on them and so then
when i see them
uh go to their screens it's more
difficult for me to say hey don't do
that because they see daddy doing it all
the time um so that's my particular
version of this
um and i know different people have
different experiences with it but how
did you come to
decide to commit an entire book which is
a very very significant commitment to
this problem
no you're so interesting what you're
saying andrew and i can't tell you how
many people i know are having the same
experience as you and
i wrote the book because i could feel my
own attention was getting significantly
worse it felt like every year that
passed things that require deep focus
like reading a book watching long films
things that are very deep to my sense of
myself were getting more and more like
running up a down escalator do you know
what i mean i could do it but it was
getting harder and harder
but to be honest and i would blame
myself i thought oh your willpower isn't
strong enough you're just not good
enough
and to be honest
i just put off thinking about it and
there was a moment in my life
which is sort of in a way a little bit
further down the line in childhood than
the experience you're having with your
kids but not so much further that made
me think
okay i need to investigate the science
of this i need to use my training in the
social sciences at cambridge university
to investigate this and i've got a
godsend i call him adam in the book it's
not his real name because didn't want to
you know out him but um when he was nine
he developed this
brief but freakishly intense obsession
with elvis i never understood where it
came from but it was unbelievably cute
he would run around singing you know
viva las vegas and suspicious minds and
he didn't know this had become like a
cheesy cliche so it was especially cute
and when i would tuck him in at night
he always got me to tell him the story
of elvis's life i tried to skip over the
bit at the end where he like shits
himself to death on the toilet but um
and and
one one night when i was tucking him in
he looked at me very intensely and he
said johann
will you take me to graceland one day
and i said yeah sure in the way that you
do with like nine year olds knowing next
week they're going to want to go
somewhere else and somewhere else and he
said to me no do you really promise will
you one day will you take me to
graceland and i said i absolutely
promise
and it never crossed my mind again until
10 years later when
everything had gone wrong so he dropped
out of school when he was 15 and by the
time he was 19 he just seemed to spend
his entire life alternating between his
ipad his laptop and his phone his life
was just passing in this blur
of whatsapp youtube tick tock porn
and it was like his mind was sort of
whirring at the speed of snapchat where
nothing still or serious could touch him
and he was he wasn't is a lovely person
but we were sitting you can't see from
the angle we're at but i was sitting on
the sofa just behind my laptop there and
i was trying to talk to him all day and
all day he was just in this sort of
fragmented state
and i was kind of disgusted with myself
exactly what you're saying with your
kids because i was looking at my own
phone the whole time
and then i suddenly remembered this
moment all those years before and i said
to him hey
let's go to graceland
and he was like what he didn't even
remember this this childhood obsession
wait wait so so so 10 years later did he
still have a fondness for elvis
right
no i don't i don't think he even no not
particularly but i was like the reason
was i wanted to do something that would
break this like numbing routine right
and i said to him and he was i could see
that it awakened something and we hadn't
been out of the country in a while um
and and i said to michael thank you
we'll go all over the south but on one
condition you've got a promise that
you'll leave your phone in the hotel
during the day right because we can't
just go around looking at snapchat the
whole time and it absolutely solemnly
swore and i believe he meant it
and two weeks later we landed in new
orleans and we went around south and
then we got to memphis
and um have you have you been to
graceland andrew i have not been to
graceland i have been in that part of
the country though but graceland has
eluded me
so far this is gonna inspire you maybe
uh so when you arrive at the gates of
graceland now this is even before
covered there's no guy to show you
around what happens is they they hand
you an ipad
and you put in earbuds and the ipad
guides you around so it says go left go
right go straight ahead whatever it
might be
and in every room you're in you get a
digital representation of that room on
the ipad and it tells you about it
so what happens is everyone walks around
graceland
just staring at their ipad right so
we're walking around half an hour and
i'm getting more and more tense and i'm
trying to make eye contact with someone
to go oh this is funny we are the people
who traveled thousands of miles and
actually looked at the place we traveled
to but the only people i could ever make
eye contact with were people who'd
looked away from the ipad to take out
their phones and take selfies so it's
getting more more and more tense and
finally we got to the jungle room which
is elvis's favorite room in graceland
was obviously
and there was a canadian couple next to
us
and the man turned to his wife and said
honey this is amazing look
if you swipe left you can see the jungle
room to the left and if you swipe right
you can see the jungle room to the right
and i thought he was joking so i laughed
and then i realized him and his wife
were just swiping back and forth and i i
turned him and i said oh but sir there's
there's an old-fashioned form of swiping
you could do called turning your head
because look we're actually in the
jungle room you don't have to look at a
digital representation we're actually
there
and this couple just backed away
thinking i was crazy and i turned to my
godson to go like god did you catch that
and he was in the corner looking at
snapchat because from the moment we
landed he just could not do it and i
felt so angry and i went up to him and i
did that thing that you're gonna be
doing with your kids soon which is
trying to snatch the phone out of his
hands and i said you know i know
you're afraid of missing out but this is
guaranteeing that you miss out you're
not showing up to your own life look at
all these people they're not present at
their own lives and he stomped off
understandably past elvis's grave out
out of graceland and i just stopped i
just wandered around on my own for a
while and i found him that night in the
heartbreak hotel where we were staying
it's just across the street and down a
bit
and he was by the swimming pool and he
was looking at his phone i went up to
him and i apologized
and he didn't look away from his phone
but he said i know something is really
wrong but i don't know what it is
and that's when i thought you know what
i've got i've got to look into this so i
ended up over the next three years going
on a really long journey all over the
world from miami to melbourne to moscow
i interviewed over 200 of the leading
experts on attention and focus and i
learned that there's 12 factors like you
say andrew that can make your attention
better or can make your attention worse
and
loads of the factors that make your
attention worse are
hugely increasing at the moment and and
the key lesson i learned is your
attention did not collapse your
attention has been stolen from you by
these big and powerful forces so with
some of your children's and we've got to
deal with this in two ways we've got to
protect ourselves and our kids at an
individual level
and we've got to take on the forces that
are stealing our focus and attention
[Music]
real talk folks how is your mental
health in 2022 is there something
preventing you from achieving your goals
anything interfering
with your happiness
we want you guys to check out our
sponsor
betterhelp.com yang i've used this
since they started sponsoring this show
andrew's used it i've recommended it to
friends it is a easy way to assess what
you need from mental standpoint and get
matched with your own licensed
professional therapist you can connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's
awesome and it's not a crisis line guys
it's not self-help it's professionally
professional counseling done securely
online you can talk to your counselor at
any time you can do them once a week at
your cadence fantastic so whether you're
dealing with depression or stress
anxiety relationships or trauma grief
for me it was just getting my mindset
right to operate in this let's call the
postcovid world right everything's
changed for me was getting on track
betterhelp was fantastic on there it's
convenient professional affordable and i
want you guys to check it out so
hopefully you guys can start living a
happier life today and as a listener to
this podcast you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
dot com
slash yang
[Music]
you know what one of the things you cite
i think was the uh
rise of cruel optimism
where where you
uh think that's like oh this is my fault
like i'm a bad parent i'm a bad person
i'm weak willed um when you realize that
our consciousness is being strip mined
by billion and trillion dollar companies
uh not just in tech but we will start
with tech
and something that tristan harris said
to me
uh that and you you know you know
tristan he said that uh it's like if uh
whale is worth more dead than alive if a
piece of lumber is worth more
in a
piece of furniture than just sitting as
a tree in nature
we kind of know what's going to happen
to the whale and the tree
and right now we are worth more
distracted upset
animated engaged outraged
angry
and so that's what we're going to be uh
because that's where the market forces
take us
um so i i'd love to inventory uh some of
these 12 reasons but i guess we'll start
with the big daddy
which you know
at least a couple chapters too and and
what tristan is focused on and what i
think many of us feel acutely which is
uh smartphone social media snapchat uh
the kind of apps that your godson's
addicted to
yeah i think tristan is one of the great
heroes of our time we're really enjoying
just being another night about this i
think he's a really
remarkable person and people who don't
know his work i really recommend they
they look him up and listen deeply to
him no you're totally right because i
was locked for a really long time in
thinking of this as a personal failure
basically if you'd asked me when i
started doing the research for this five
years ago why why is attention getting
worse i would was your attention getting
worse i would have said well basically
i'm weak and my phone came along and
invaded me and i learned that actually
that's way too simplistic a way of
thinking about it but because i was
locked in that initial mode the first
thing i did for the book is i spent
three months completely off the internet
which by the way i envied when you
described your writing retreat
anyway when i was like oh my gosh like
who wouldn't want to do that it was you
know it was an incred there were some
real lows and some real crashes where i
desperately craved the rewards of social
media but what amazed me about that
experience
is how much my mind came back because i
thought you know i'm nearly 43. i
thought can you get older your brain
deteriorates you mistake your own
we're well past our intellectual primes
johan we're just going to be churning
out second rate
just exactly the slow descent into
similarity but actually
my attention went back to what it had
been when i was 17. i could sit and read
a book for eight hours a day and focus
deeply now there are lots of changes
that happened to me when i was in
provincetown away from the internet that
i realized of course that it wasn't just
the absence of social media and i'm sure
we'll talk about a lot of the others but
at the end of my time in provincetown
i was like
i'm never going to go back to that way
of living my god why why would i ever go
back to that
and i got my phone back and within two
months i didn't ever go back to being as
bad as i'd been before but within two
months i was basically 80 back to where
i'd been right
and i only understood why when i went to
interview james williams
dr james williams incredible um person
who was a former senior strategist at
google
horrified by what they were doing to
people was being hijacked by his own
creations quit and became one of the
world's leading experts on attention and
james said to me you've made a
fundamental mistake here
in provincetown although it was great
i'm sure it was great he said um
you've acted like the solution to air
pollution is for you personally to wear
a gas mask
and look i'm not against gas masks if i
lived in beijing i'd wear a gas mask
there's a place for individual relief it
has real value but he said we've got to
tackle this problem at the source we've
got to deal with the reasons why our
attention is being invaded because at
the moment it's like someone is pouring
itching powder over us all day and then
they're leaning forward and going you
know buddy
you might want to learn how to meditate
then you wouldn't scratch so much to
which the obvious response is yeah i'll
learn to meditate that's all very good
and i'm in favor of it but you need to
stop pouring inching powder on me but
i'm making money pouring itching powder
on you yourself
pouring itching powder on you exactly it
becomes more like how are you how are
you going to stop how are you going to
stop me sensible regulation
you really did sound like a batman
villain there i was very impressed um
well it was so interesting because i
obviously there's two levels of which
you've got to tackle this like i said
before they're in my book style and
focus i go through loads of things we
can do as individuals and and i want to
be honest i'm strongly in favor of
individual action at a personal level it
can really help but we've got a level
with people
that will only get you so far and in an
environment that is pro the way
professor joel nigg one of the leading
experts on children's attention in the
world said to me we live in what he
called an attentional pathogenic
environment one that is systematically
degrading everyone's ability to pay
attention professor barbara domini one
of the leading scientists in france
she's won the legend their biggest
civilian award said to me it is not
possible to have a normal brain today so
if we want to think about you've gone to
exactly the right point andrew you've
gone to the heart of the issue because
you're obviously so well informed about
this which is
the business model the business
incentives so there was a moment with
this
obviously i spent a lot of time in
silicon valley talking to many
dissidents who a lot of people will have
heard of are like tristan
who's such a remarkable person
well i i will say i disagree with
tristan on some of this stuff because i
have said to tristan i was like hey
tristan all the stuff you're talking
about
is is not going to work because they're
making billions of dollars pouring
itching powder on us
and that the only way to counteract it
is to uh put a spike in these incentives
like a you know like a stake in the
heart of the the beast
uh so one of the things i recommend in
my book is look require everyone to move
to a non-ad supported uh business model
and my idea for that was just for the
government just to say everyone gets a
20 buck
a month stipend that will you can then
use to transition to ad supported oh
sorry not ad free versions of all your
favorite social media companies and then
the incentives would become more sane uh
but i just wanted to to let you know
it's like i love tristan i admire him a
lot he and i have talked about this and
i think he's too benign
[Laughter]
i think he's moving i totally i agree i
think he's moving in your direction
and uh he i think he's he's he's someone
you know it's so interesting because if
you look at a lot of these people who
are accused of being cassandra's in
silicon valley
they're so far from being cassandra's
they're reasonable pragmatic people who
just want to solve a problem and and
there was a moment where tristan and
various other people were exactly that
point you're making fell into place for
me so tristan said to me you open
facebook
and it'll tell you lots of things right
it'll tell you whose birthday it is
it'll tell you what you said on that
same day 10 years ago it'll tell you
who
you know who tagged you in a post or we
all know the list right there's one
thing it doesn't have there's no button
that says something like i'd like to
meet up with my friends if any of my
other friends indicated they'd like to
meet up right doesn't exist now the
minute i say that everyone who's on
facebook think that'd be a really useful
app right i'd like to you know get to a
friday night who wants to meet up
there's there's no obvious mechanism to
figure that out using facebook it'd be
hugely popular with its users so
why does why doesn't the market provide
it and the answer is very obvious i know
you know really well andrew every time
you open facebook they make money in two
ways
obviously you see ads but more
importantly they harvest all the
information you provide to build up a
profile of you to sell it to advertisers
they're commodifying your attention and
selling it to the highest bidder this is
crucial to the attention debate because
as sean parker one of the biggest
initial investors in facebook said we
designed it to maximally invade people's
attention we knew what we were doing and
we did it anyway god only knows what
it's doing to our kids this is now i'm
sure a familiar debate
to all of your listeners um but i think
if you
what's so important is when you
understand those incentives you can see
why for example there's no button that
says let's meet up because of course
then you would go and meet up with your
friend you would look into his face he
wouldn't be two hours off of facebook
exactly
exactly all of the interaction they want
is through the rap and of course that's
only gonna become more and more extreme
as they move towards the metaverse and
the other sort of slightly disturbed
it's funny there's a guy called jaron
lanier who i think you probably know
yeah yeah he's been on the pod jaron uh
lanier
technology is very genius yeah great a
complete guru like almost literally a
guru i think but he he said to me you
know he used to be a consultant on loads
of dystopian movies like minority report
but he stopped doing it because what he
would do is he would design some
horrific technology that was his idea of
a nightmare and then those people watch
it technologies and go
that's a great idea how do we make that
and he was like no no this is not what i
wanted so you're absolutely right when
you tease out the implications to social
media
there's a historical analogy that i
think really helps us to understand what
you're proposing
um so you'll just about remember this
andrew i vaguely remember it from my
childhood it used to be perfectly normal
in fact the standard for people to use
leaded petrol in their cars load of
gasoline in their cars and for people to
paint their homes with leaded paint
and it was known going way back to
ancient rome the exposure to lead really
harms your brain in fact scientists by
the 1920s were warning that leaded
gasoline would cause a disaster for
people's brains but the lead industry
funded an enormous machinery of lies and
denial fake science we all know that
model from the climate crisis to deny it
and tonight and deny it but by the time
you got to the late 1970s the early
1980s the evidence that exposure to lead
was damaging children's brains and
particularly their ability to focus and
pay attention
was absolutely overwhelming and so what
did we do we didn't ban lead we didn't
ban paint
you know you can see my apartment is
painted right i can see yours is i can
see cars going yeah we just switched to
unleaded gasoline and exactly that free
paint we dealt with the specific element
and this to me is so important because
the way
they
the way the tech industry wants to frame
people like you and me and tristan
is they want this debate to be framed as
pro-tech or anti-tech right and if it's
framed like that firstly it's not true
but secondly it just induces fatalism in
people because they're like well i'm not
going to join the amish i'm not going to
give up my devices so i guess we just
have to be pro-tech the question is not
are you pro-tech or anti-tech the
question is what tech working in whose
interests
with what effects and so we can have
just like we have all the benefits of
paint but not lead paint we can have the
benefits of social media without them
being designed maximally to hack our
attention it's exactly the shift you
suggest aza raskiner i think you
probably also know invented a key part
of how the internet works his dad jeff
raskin invented the apple mac for steve
jobs he said to me look step one of the
solution is really simple you've got to
ban the current business model just like
we do not allow yes you just say you are
not allowed to have a business model
that is based on identifying the
weaknesses of people's attention hacking
them and selling their attention to the
highest bidder you just forbid it and i
remember because i was an earlier i was
i knew much less about this debate then
than you do now
i said to aza and lots of the other
people who proposed this
okay but let's say we do that
what happens the next day when i open
facebook because on twitter and does it
just say sorry we've gone fishing and he
said of course not what would happen is
they would move to an alternative
business model i love your way of
incentivizing it but the key thing to
understand about the alternative
business models
is is why that leads to a different
effect on your attention so let's think
about two possible alternative business
models that everyone listening has had
experience with the first is
subscription we all know how netflix
yeah
love it the second the second
is your apartment my apartment is
connected to the sewage systems before
we had sewers we had you know feces in
the street we had outbreaks of cholera
so all of us together pay to build the
sewers and maintain the sewers you own
the sewers of new york city i own the
sewers of las vegas and london places
where i live right um you wait wait you
live in vegas no i'm kidding
it's because of a book i'm writing it's
a long story i'll tell you all the time
but the but yeah and it's an amazing
place um but the the
it may be that just like we own the
sewage pipes together we want to own the
information pipes together because we're
getting the attentional equivalent of
cholera and the key thing is
once we move to this different business
model
exactly like you say andrew all the
incentives change at the moment every
incentive for these machines
sorry for the people who currently run
the social media companies doesn't
matter if they're nice people or
horrible people yes all of their
incentives are one thing how do i get
andrew to pick up his phone more and
scroll more and how do i get andrew's
kids to pick up his phone more and
scroll more that's it
just same way the head of kfc all he
cares about is did andrew any kfc today
that's it that's all he cares about
right don't matter if he's nice or nasty
but the whole thing at the moment is
designed to maximally invade your
attention now of course there's a degree
to which when these technologies were
invented they would have had some effect
on our attention anyway and i can talk
about some of the ways they do and what
we can do about that
but they have been designed to maximally
invade our attention they can just as
easily be designed to maximally heal our
attention once you're the customer in
this different business model and not
the product facebook can start to ask
yourself well what does andrew want oh
andrew wants to meet up with his friends
let's give him a button to meet up with
his friends yep you could actually
become a life enhancement instead of an
attention degrader
exactly and for all of the 12 causes
of uh attention problems that i write
about in in stolen focus
they're all of them but one there's
there's two levels like this there's
lots of stuff we can do to protect
ourselves and we can talk about that as
individuals but we've got to take on
these forces in the same way that the
lead industry was never going to just
give up putting lead in pain and petrol
right they had no i'm i'm sure they just
woke up and had a crisis of conscience
here come on
i mean it's hard to they said we're
tired of making money
exactly we've made enough
and we
we've done enough let's have a good life
in our house made of lead where we go
slowly and say that our children can't
think or speak anymore um
exactly and i think this requires uh
it was one of the things that i had to
do in my own mind as i was working on
the book
is really shift consciousness on this
because for a long time i thought of
this as a failure of willpower right
and actually had a real really
interesting that's very american of you
johan it's like you know rugged
individual is um like
i spent way too much time in the united
states so it's like god damn it it's on
me right
and i remember having a moment very
early in the research for the book i
went to interview a guy called professor
roy baumeister who's at the university
of queensland in australia
and he's the leading expert in the world
on willpower he wrote a book called
willpower i'm sure everyone's heard of
the marshmallow test he's the guy who
invented that so i go to interview him
and i said you know i'm thinking of
writing a book about why people have got
attention problems trying to figure it
out and he said oh
it's really interesting you say that
because i just find myself these days
just playing games on my phone all the
time i just find you know my own
attention isn't very good i say there's
like wait didn't you write a book called
willpower i was like aren't you the
strongest willed person in the world
literally all the scientific evidence
about willpower but if you're in an
environment that invades you you're not
gonna be able you can defend yourself to
some degree and i realize the shift in
consciousness i think we have to make on
this issue and there's a shift in
consciousness on the other 11 issues as
well but on this issue
if you can't focus if you can't pay
attention
it's not your fault there's not
something wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with your children
we are not medieval peasants begging at
the court of king zuckerberg for a few
little crumbs of attention from his
table we are the free citizens of
democracies and we own our own minds and
we can reclaim them from the forces that
are systematically degrading them if we
want to but we have to understand this
as a systemic problem that requires
systemic solutions as well as to some
degree an individual problem that we
have to deal with individually we have
to do both and just like they're needed
and obviously still needs to be a
feminist movement to reclaim women's
bodies and their lives i would argue we
need an attention movement to take on
these big forces that are degrading our
ability to think they've created what
professor earl miller one of the leading
neuroscientists in the world calls a
perfect storm of cognitive degradation
we've got to take on these forces not
least because and you know this much
better than i do andrew
these forces are only going to become
more invasive if we don't act it's like
we're in a race so to one side
let's think about this one of the 12
causes not the biggest cause by the way
affecting our attention which we might
get to but think about this cause
on the one side think about paul graham
one of the leading investors in silicon
valley who said the world is on course
to be much more addictive in the next 40
years than the last 40 years think about
how much more compelling to your child
tick-tock is than facebook right we
imagine that level of investment the
problem with tick-tock videos is they're
a little bit too long
you know
my idea is a new app called tick
the and the maximum
length of a video
2.5 seconds
and then i will launch your rival called
which will be oh no you're going to beat
me exactly so if you think of it as a
race right you on the one side you've
got this increasingly invasive
technology what we've got to have on the
other side
is a movement of ordinary people saying
no
you don't get to do this to us you don't
get to do this to our children and of
course that movement's begun people like
tristan the center for humane technology
which everyone should sign up to and
there's a go through at the back of the
book just a huge range of organizations
that are fighting on the different
dimensions of this issue but we've got
to take on these forces because if we
don't my worry is that this could be
like the obesity crisis or the climate
crisis which is the harder the further
in you get the harder it is to get back
and this relates to a deeper thing about
attention everyone listening or watching
if you just think about anything you've
ever achieved in your life
you know whether it's setting up a
business being a good parent learning to
play the guitar whatever it might be
that thing that you're proud of took a
huge amount of sustained attention and
focus
and attention and focus are now breaking
down the average office worker now
focuses on any one task but only three
minutes for every one child who was
diagnosed with attention problems when i
was seven years old there's now a
hundred children diagnosed that way and
when attention breaks and that's a real
because there's a real problem and when
attention breaks down your ability to
achieve your goals
and solves your and solve your problems
breaks down right
a person who's adult who can't focus
is much less effective in the world and
my worry is it's going to take a lot of
attention and focus to reclaim our
attention and focus and if we become
more and more adult and we're on a
downward trajectory right if you look at
the evidence on this i think it's pretty
clear
uh we're on a significant downward
trajectory it can be it's a bit like
when you i've had periods of my life
when i've been obese it can be a bit
like when you put on so much weight
that it's really hard to exercise
and lose the weight right and my worry
is if we don't act quite quickly on this
question to protect ourselves and our
children we're going to go deeper and
deeper into this attention crisis i
think this is really urgent
[Music]
so the the main detriment is that in the
u.s
the government doesn't care what we
think
uh or what's good for us
that's like the fundamental problem
that's a pretty big problem i will agree
with you that's a big issue yeah yeah
they don't understand technology either
uh their
resources on these issues are generally
the tech companies themselves
one organization doing great work on
this space politically is common sense
media which is largely a group of
parents who figured out that this stuff
is toxic for our kids it's run by a guy
named jim steyer
so there is uh and the data by the way
is like if you ask parents hey would you
want common sense regulation on
apps uh so that our kids brains aren't
fried shockingly most parents are like
heck yes
and then
and then the but the parents feel right
now to completely outgunned they're
largely ignored
by congress
um so
one of the approaches i've taken which
you might appreciate johann is
it is a very american argument um and
it's also very me
which is to say look look
our data is ours um we should not allow
these companies to essentially sell and
resell it for hundreds of billions of
dollars for their own benefit we should
get some of that money
uh or we should say we can turn it off
and there is some legislation in
california that inaugurated a new
consumer data protection agency
and we want to replicate that nationwide
so if you are someone who lives in a
state other than california you should
be yelling at your state legislators hey
why do californians have data rights
that we don't have
um i started something called the data
dividend project trying to get people
paid for their data which you could you
can and when listening to this can look
up or or join
now
the short-term way to get people money
is successful lawsuits against tech
companies which most people don't hear
about but yahoo and facebook
and tic-tac are paying tens of millions
of dollars for screwing up with people's
data and then you know no individuals
might get
60 bucks or 80 bucks but hey you know
it's like like that that's like a
beginning um because my thought on this
is that if you can get people excited
about their own data rights and possibly
getting paid for them
then you can catalyze more popular
excitement
around trying to beat back the tech
companies but there does need to be
legislation there does need to be a
movement that the problem for us here in
the us johann is that you can have a
movement and it just falls on deaf ears
uh in dc and congress
another thing i've done to try and make
these things happen is i've started
hiring lobbyists on capitol hill who are
just like hey you know what people would
like
child tax credit they really love that
thing hey you know what people would
like some common sense
uh restrictions on some of these social
media apps so that their kids are more
sane and healthy so i'm working it but
you should know i completely endorse
everything you're saying and we need to
go further and upend the business models
of these companies because everything
else is going to be a half measure
i think what you're doing is so
important and i write about it in the
book and i'm passionately in favor of it
i think there's another level at which
your work can help us to solve another
aspect of the attention crisis if you're
right for me to talk about that because
and it's another place we have a cameo
in the book so i think the way into
understanding it is to go back whatever
it is 18 19 months now to the start of
covid so when lots of us realized we
were going to be shut away in our homes
many people
um it's kind of i remember a lot less
people saying oh i'm i'm going to be
shut away at home for ages i'll finally
read war and peace i'll learn french
i'll you know people had these big
ambitious attention-based projects
and
no one read war and peace and no one
learned french you know what we did do
johan we did watch tiger king
well that was yeah that was that was um
like a horrific fever dream as far as
i'm concerned but the the googling of
terms like how do i get my brain to
focus increased by like three
if you want to understand why i think if
you understand why people found it so
hard to focus under covid it leads to
one of your big and best and most
brilliant issues i interviewed a woman
called dr nadine burke harris so i think
you might know she's the surgeon general
of california yes uh ace the the trauma
research uh she's brilliant a complete
hero i mean one of the most remarkable
people i've ever met yes people who
don't know nadine i really recommend
people look look her up and look up her
work she's uh
an extraordinary person fighting for
some of the most vulnerable people
and and and they didn't explain to me
when i interviewed the stress this was
pre-covered so i'm interpreting it in
like covet she wasn't doing that
um
she said to me look imagine one day
you're walking down the street and
you're attacked by a bear out the blue
and you survive
in the weeks and months that follow
something involuntary will happen to
your attention you'll become more
vigilant so it'll be harder for you to
focus on things directly in front of you
like a book because a big part of your
mind will just be scanning for risk and
danger it's completely involuntary
because something attacked you out of
the blue so your mind is just like jeez
what else is going to attack me out the
blue okay now imagine you were attacked
by a bear again
you might well flip into a state called
hyper vigilance hyper vigilance is when
you cannot focus on the thing in front
of you because you are so anxious about
what might just
i i just want to say if you get attacked
by
bears twice
then you're being careless what's the
thing oscar wilde said you know uh once
a misfortune twice begins to look like
carelessness
like are you like walking around bear
territory with like a steak attached to
your back
[Laughter]
so i'll finish this point about
stressing it about uh vigilance in a
minute but it reminds me of one of the
worst things i've ever witnessed in my
life which is i once gave a speech in
banff
and i was in a place where
they um
there are bears so they give you bear
spray you know it's like mace you
sprained i mean no one had ever been
attacked by a bear but just in case as
you're walking around they give you m
they give you bear spray but there was
someone there who didn't speak english
very well and she misunderstood it and
she thought bear spray was like bug
spray that you spray it on yourself no
she sprayed it into her own face she is
designed to stop a bear and she sprayed
it into her own face it was horrific
anyway so
set aside that horrific image so if
you're attacked by a bear again you will
likely go into a state called hyper
vigilance and hyper vigilance is where
you cannot focus on the things in front
of you because you are scanning for risk
and a a wonderful child psychiatrist in
adelaide in australia said to me
deep focus and attention are a really
good strategy when you're safe sitting
down and reading a book is great you'll
grow you'll learn more
deep focus is a very stupid strategy if
you're in danger right you want to be
looking for out for risk if you're in
danger you'd be a fool if you sat at the
battle of the somme and and you know and
and read a novel right
so
we can focus best when we feel safe
one of the things well i think in covid
we couldn't focus because we were scared
of the virus we were scared that our
lives had been profoundly upended we
didn't know what was coming next we're
in this bizarre situation
but i also think it helps us to
understand another factor that's been
undermining attention for a long time
which is financial insecurity this
evidence the more financially insecure
you are the more you struggle to focus
and it's a bit like the bear attack
if you've ever been broke and i have and
there'll be lots of people listening you
have
one thing going wrong can screw you
right one financial setback one one flat
tire yeah one unexpected bill yeah
totally exactly as you talked about so
brilliantly during the campaign
um so
you can see that we're flipped into this
mode of hypervision and the reason this
is so important is in finland as you
know much better than i do they did an
experiment with a universal basic income
where they chose a group of people at
random and they gave them uh i think it
was 750 us dollars a month and there
were many interesting results all of
which your listeners don't need to tell
them about because you've you're far
more articulate on this than i am
but there was a really interesting one i
interviewed professor olavi kangas who
did that research monitor was in charge
of monitoring the outcomes
one thing they found was a really
significant improvement in people's
ability to focus and pay attention
if you give people a baseline of
security and stability
they are safer and they can attend more
to what's in front of them
and then they're less vigilant there's
other interesting research on this
there's a guy called sending nathan
professor milan nathan did this this
this research that reinforces this point
he studied indian sugarcane farmers
and basically because it's seasonal at
the start of the season they're broke
they've burned through their money from
the previous season they're broke and
then at the end of the season they are
um
they've got much more money
and he tested their iq when they were
broke and when they had money they
scored 13 iq points better when they had
money than when they didn't because it
just screws your intelligence and it
screws your attention
if you're anxious and scanning for risk
stress
if we anything we do that reduces stress
improves and enhances attention over
time another is the increasingly
invasive technology and some of the
effects that it has on us there's also a
whole range of obviously 10 other
factors oh let let's let's do the
inventory like oh um and you we'd have
to go through all 10 list style but but
some of the others are
uh nutrition exhaustion pollution uh but
yeah just because i'm sure for most
people going into this they were like
okay this is a tech thing um but it is
much bigger than that well that was what
surprised me
in a way i started to think about the
tech in relation to the other causes
because i started to think of the
technology as like a virus right it
would have been potent at any time but
it arrived at a moment when our
collective immune system was already
down because there had already been a
big series of changes that were
profoundly damaging our ability to focus
and pay attention i'll give you two very
quick examples
we sleep much less than people used to
we sleep an hour less than people did in
1942 children sleep 85 minutes less than
they did a century ago and when children
don't sleep they become manic the last
quarter of the book is all about
children and what's happened to them and
i spent a lot of time interviewing the
leading experts in the world on sleep
and there were so many chilling moments
on this but one was with a guy called dr
charles seisler have you ever spoken to
him if not i really recommend having him
on your show oh i'll enjoy you if you
want a completely amazing man and and he
did a series of experiments that really
haunted me so one of the things he
discovered is if you stay awake for 19
hours which really doesn't sound like
much to me
your attention becomes as bad as if you
had got legally drunk
if you just go for nine days
only sleeping six hours a night your
attention becomes as bad as if you were
legally drunk i'm pretty sure i did that
on the presidential but
you're all drunk
exactly the um and um yeah i can't
imagine the horror of that and and um he
did this experiment where they combined
two forms of technology
they put people in a machine that can it
scans your eyes and sees what you're
looking at and it scans your brain to
see what's happening there and what he
discovered is when you're tired and you
don't have to be that tired
literally whole parts of your brain have
gone to sleep the technical term for
this is local sleep because it's local
to one part of the brain so you appear
to be awake but you are half asleep um
and this is because i also want to
explore this a lot and i go through it a
lot in the book but um dr professor
roxanne prichard a brilliant person at
the university of minneapolis where i
interviewed her explain to me the key
reason key reasons why
when your brain when you're when you're
sleeping
your brain is repairing itself it's
cleaning itself your cerebral spinal
fluid channels open up they're rinsed
through with a watery fluid that carries
out all the metabolic waste which she
calls like brain cell poop that builds
up throughout the day carries it down to
your liver and takes it out of your body
if you don't sleep your brain does not
repair properly and so it's it's
literally impaired and she explained of
course we evolved so that you could
sometimes go without sleep we wouldn't
be able to raise children or escape
hurricanes if we couldn't do it
sometimes
but when you don't sleep your body
interprets that as an emergency
and it puts all sort of emergency
measures in place it stops you thinking
about other things it lowers your
cognitive ability it raises your heart
rate it raises your blood pressure it
makes you crave more sweet snacks so
that's one example right we sleep dr
seisler said to me
even if nothing else had changed even if
all that happened is that us and our
kids sleep much less that alone would be
causing a really big attention crisis
[Music]
i'll give you an example another one of
the twelve
which is the way we eat
um and i've interviewed a lot of people
there's this fascinating new movement
called nutritional psychiatry of people
who are studying the effects
of the way we eat on our brains
depression
anxiety i talk about this a lot in the
book and i interviewed many of the
leading figures if you want to talk to
any of the mandarin introduce you
because they're totally fascinating
people um but this has a particular
effect on our attention there's three
ways in which the way we eat at the
moment is prof and i include myself you
can't see this but there's a kfc box
literally behind my laptop so i don't
say this with any sense of superiority
well one thing i was going to joke about
johann is that at this point you've been
broke obese and
uh
tension
starved and so i'm like uh i'm like a
character like a 1930s melodrama you
know those black and white films
starring barbara's stomach i had a real
low point in my life related to kfc
remind me to say the other things about
food in his again but
in 2009 uh on christmas eve it makes it
even sadder 2009 i went to my local kfc
which was in a place part of east london
called brick lane
and and i went in there it was lunch
time and i said my my typical order
which is so disgusting i won't even
repeat it
and the guy behind the counter said oh
johan i'm really glad you're here wait a
minute no it's like all right and he
went off behind where they throw the
chicken and he came back with all the
other people who were on duty that day
and they'd got a massive christmas card
in which they'd written to our best
customer
and everyone who worked there had
written me like personal messages and
one of the reasons my heart sank is i
thought this isn't even the fried
chicken shop i come to the most
so this is like my second favorite
i never went back but because i was so
horrified but like two years later i
bumped into that guy in the street and
he said oh yeah you never came back we
just assumed you died of a heart attack
i was like oh my god what's happening
anyway so
this diet this standard western diet
that most of us eat
and
it affects our ability to focus and pay
attention profoundly in three ways and
the first is
let's say for breakfast you have i don't
know white white bread or you have
frosties or whatever it might be
pop-tarts
exactly pop-tarts even the words
pop-tarts has given me such an intense
craving i can't tell you but i'm gonna
fight through it and what that does and
pop-tarts in particular actually
is they and i learned this from dale
pinnock who's one of the leading
nutritionists in britain
is it releases a huge amount of energy
really quickly so you feel great you
feel like you've woken up but then an
hour later
your energy you're sitting at your desk
or your child is sitting at their school
desk and your energy will just crash it
will slump and you'll experience brain
fog where you just can't get your head
to work properly until you have another
sugary carby snack and the way so at the
moment
the western diet puts us on a kind of
constant roller coaster of mental energy
spikes and mental energy crashes and
we're often in a state of brain fog the
way dale pinnock put it to me
is it's like we're putting rocket fuel
into a mini right one of those little
british cars from the 70s it'll go
really fast for five minutes and then
it'll just stop but when you eat a diet
that releases energy steadily throughout
the day which is of course what humans
evolve doing
your energy will be much easier to apply
there are two other quick ways in which
it affects your ability to pay attention
the way we eat one is
that for your brain to develop and
function fully you need certain
nutrients and our diet is chronically
lacking many of those nutrients and
there was a really interesting study in
the netherlands where they got a bunch
of kids i think it was a 130 kids and
they split them into two groups and one
was assigned to basically cut out the
we eat and just eat healthy stuff
and the other was
you know carried on eating this kind of
standard diet
and the group that shifted to the
healthy diet
that um 70 of them had an improvement in
their attention and the average
improvement was 50 which is remarkable
um so that's one element we're not
getting the things we need for our
brains to develop the other is even more
disturbing which is the food we and
particularly our children eat contains
chemicals that act on us like drugs
there was a study in britain in
southampton in 2007. they took 297 kids
and they split them into two groups one
group was given just water to drink and
the other group was given a cocktail um
not alcoholic cocktails that'd be weird
a cocktail of uh chemicals basically
that are in the kind of food that we
give our kids all the time stuff from
the supermarket m m's candies
and the kids given the cocktail of
chemicals were significantly more likely
to become manic to become
to act up to have attention problems so
you can see across the board the way
we're eating is damaging and again it's
tempting to think of that in an
individualistic way you know that oh
this is just a personal failing and of
course there are things we can do as
individuals no no i mean
again they're these billion dollar
companies that are just like hey like i
can make a bit more money
my food's a little bit more addictive
it's a little bit a little bit cheaper
it stays on the shelf longer and we're
locked in that machinery you know more
18 month old children know what the
mcdonald's m means than know their own
last name
yo johan one one of the things that
blows my mind as a parent well first my
kids love mcdonald's um but but second
things are the same price now that they
were when i was growing up and i was
like wow like how the heck do they still
make this stuff happen for every so
little you go in there and like you
could get
you know a happy meal for like a few
bucks
like the whole thing it's
uh it's wild i grew up on that stuff too
uh and if you were financially
struggling
be like a million times easier to get
your kids a meal at one of these fast
food places then try and get some fresh
produce especially because there are
food deserts all over the country in
terms of fresh food if you don't have
money in mcdonald's is much easier but
also
um if you're stressed
you crave that food much more it does
relieve stress in a strangely way that's
why they call it comfort food
exactly and if you're tired you crave
that food more and that's something
that's true
of so many of the factors that i write
about in in stolen focus
of these 12 factors
they all interact right they all
interact they reinforce each other
exactly so it's like we create a kind of
disastrous spiral um and it goes
downward and downward and downward um
but
and this is why
one of the reasons i really admire you
andrew
it's very easy
when there are people living in drainage
tunnels beneath caesar's palace when
there are people who have diabetes who
don't get insulin in the united states
when there are when we can't agree on
the most basic things
it's very tempting
to get into a mode of fatalism right
like i wrote a book about addiction uh
called chasing the scream and the war on
drugs because we had addiction in my
family
and in one of the things i explained the
book is why i explain what causes
addiction but also i explain the
countries that solved addiction crises
that had enormous election crises and
solve them like and i know you've talked
about this portugal where they
decriminalized all drugs and took all
the money they used to spend on shaming
people punishing them and putting them
in prison and they spent it all on
helping them and they went from having
the worst drug problem in the european
union to being having the lowest drug
problem in the european union and an
enormous fallen overdose deaths and i
would go around the united states and i
would talk about that and people even
you know quite conservative people would
say when they heard the argument and
they listened to the stories i present
in the book and they see the scientific
evidence from portugal they'd say you're
absolutely right and it will never
happen here there is a
deep fatalism and one things i love
about you is our job is to be hope
mongers um and one of the reasons i'm
hopeful when people say oh let's think
back about tech right very often people
will say to me
and people have been saying to me as i
talk about the book
um
yeah you know
you're right about these factors you're
right about everything johan
i wish everywhere i go people just say
yeah and you're right about everything
uh sadly not when you're right about
this that's for sure but then they say
hey this will never actually get
addressed
and when i say that
i think about some specific people but
i'll and i'm happy to talk about plenty
of them but i'll just tell you two
people very close to me i urge people to
think about their own families i think
about my grandmothers
so my grandmothers were the age i am now
i'm 43 in a few days
and they were the age i am now in 1963.
one of them was a working-class woman in
a scottish tenement a kind of very poor
like housing like uh like a housing
project and one of them was a swiss
peasant woman living in a wooden hut on
the side of a mountain in switzerland
both my grandmothers left school when
they were 13 because when the men in
their family stayed on longer because no
one gave a about girls learning
anything my swiss grandmother wasn't
brilliant at drawing and painting they
told her to shut up and get into the
kitchen and put it away
my grandmothers when they were the age i
am now
they were not allowed to have bank
accounts
because they were married women in their
own name
they were not allowed my swiss
grandmother wasn't allowed to vote
it was legal for their husbands to rape
them as it was legal everywhere in the
world for men to rape their wives it was
in practice legal for men to beat the
out their wives because there was
not one domestic violence refuge
anywhere in the world
men controlled
literally everything there was not a
company not a country
not a police force that was controlled
by women that and there never had been
apart from a few hereditary monarchs
right
and i think about
how enormous the power structure that
faced them was and how it profoundly
thwarted their lives right my
grandmothers were incredible people they
were good kind intelligent people and
they never got to have the lives they
should have had and then i think about
my niece who's 17 who sadly never knew
my grandmother either of my grandmothers
but my niece loves to draw and when my
niece loved to draw we didn't say shut
up and get into the kitchen we said hey
let's look up art schools now i do not
want to underestimate how much further
we've got to go how deep the fight
against misogyny is i'm very conscious
of how irritating it is from man to
mansplain this but we have let led to an
astonishing transformation there has
been an astonishing transformation as a
result of the feminist movement and when
when people say to me i will never
will never win against these forces i
always say to them however powerful big
tech is how powerful the food industry
is however powerful all these other
forces that i write about and stolen
focus are they ain't a hundredth as
powerful as men were in 1963 right men
controlled
everything literally everything right
and always had done so there are
incredible changes that are possible
when we organize exactly in the way
you're doing in the way so many other
people are doing and we fight back and a
big part of our job is explaining to
people they want you to feel powerless
and without agency you are incredibly
powerful the people i've got to know all
over the world who created it i'll give
you one other example when i get
pessimistic and there are days when i
feel pessimistic i think a lot about
someone i'm sure most of your listeners
know about a good friend of mine named
andrew solomon so in 1994
andrew was diagnosed as hiv positive it
was the height of the aids crisis his
best friend patrick had just died of
aids as far as he knew there was no hope
in sight
he thought he had a couple of years to
live so andrew quit his job he was the
editor of the new republic and he went
to provincetown to die
and he decided
that before he died
he was going to do one last thing
he was going to write a book about a
crazy utopian idea that no one had ever
written a book about before and he
thought well i'll never live to see this
happen no one alive today will ever live
to see this happen but maybe somewhere
down the line someone will pick this up
the idea he wrote the first book about
was gay marriage amazing book called
virtually normal when i get pessimistic
i try to imagine going back in time to
provincetown in in in 2004
and saying to andrew okay andrew you're
not going to believe me
but whatever it is
26 years from now
a you'll be alive that would have blown
his mind b you'll be married to a man
that would have been inconceivable to
him and c i'll be with you when the
supreme court of the united states
quotes from this book you're writing now
when it makes it mandatory for every
state in the united states to introduce
gay marriage and the next day you'll be
invited to a white house lit up in the
colours of the rainbow flag to have
dinner with the president to celebrate
what you and so many other people have
achieved oh and by the way
that president he's going to be black
right every aspect of that would have
sounded like
preposterous science fiction let me say
to you sir andrew 26 years from now
a trans president is going to invite us
to smoke crack with her in the oval
office right it will just not that we
want that oh and and they'll be quoting
from stolen focus as they write
they're requiring you as they write uh
legislation to completely change the
business model i i will say i agree with
you that
we probably don't have that much time uh
that if we're going to to make this
stuff happen um it's going to be a
little bit sooner but continue you know
i we i understand that that yeah that
this
this is an illustration that incredible
things are possible that might be beyond
the imagination of most people and i
completely
agree with you that there is a massive
need for this movement and my thinking
on it is this
we are setting our kids up to fail for a
host of reasons
but one of them is that they're anxious
they're depressed their minds are
getting strip mined they're not able to
focus and pay attention
and in that environment it's going to be
very difficult for them to
have the kind of lives that we want for
them and so if we want to turn that
around
we have to get back our
data our minds our autonomy our humanity
our agency
and imagining that individuals can
somehow
protect themselves from billion and
trillion dollar corporations
uh is ridiculous what roger mcnamee said
is that in the old days when they did
industrial production you just dump the
chemicals in the back and then at some
point someone realized you know what
those chemicals end up seeping into the
river and then end up poisoning people
you should probably have some rules
around
about disposing of them
uh you know the same thing's happening
right now with these tech companies and
social media apps and the rest of it
it's like okay
uh we get it these things uh are
part of our lives but there's no reason
why we have to accept the equivalent of
the chemical spill and say well like you
know like i guess now our kids are going
to be anxious and and not able to
concentrate at all
[Music]
up to now
almost all of the debate has been
focused upon individual changes
and i'm passionately in favor of
individual changes this is one reason i
love your book johan is that you call it
like it is it's like look like expecting
us to do this individually is
yeah i mean look there are things you
can do and it'll it might help you 20
i'd say the changes i've made which are
really significant and i talk about in
the book have boosted personally my
attention by about 20
that's def even if i had nothing else
that would be worth doing
but
i mean it's in the sense of
it's
professor joel nigg one of the leading
experts on children's attention problems
you know
he just said to me look if you see
bodies coming down the river you can
fish the bodies out the river that's
worth doing but you've got to go upriver
to see why the bodies are coming down in
the first place and in the same way
we've got to figure out why this is
happening and the science is very clear
on this right yeah that was one thing
that was striking to me the evidence for
how this is degrading our attention and
focus and it comes back to that thing
exactly what you're saying about
efficacy remember dr james williams the
attention amazing attention expert said
to me you know the axe existed for 1.4
million years before anyone thought to
put a handle on it the entire world wide
web has existed for less than 10 000
days we can change these things if we
want to
but i think you just said before andrew
that was so important as well
about children because there's
there's been an extraordinary rise in
children struggling to focus and pay
attention
and
i don't think it's a coincidence
and this is very relevant to the current
covert debate as well
i don't think it's a coincidence that
this extraordinary explosion in
children's attention problems
coincided with a profound transformation
in the nature of childhood itself and i
tell this in the book partly through the
story of an incredible woman called
lenores genazi and so lenore
like everyone else who grew up in the
60s
lenore i mean this will seem almost
unbelievable to people who who who hear
it now
so lenore up in a suburb of chicago
normal suburb
when she was five from when she was five
years old she would walk out the house
on her own and she would walk to school
which was 15 minutes away on her own i
mean she would bump into the other kids
on the way
she would be helped across the road when
she got to the school by a ten-year-old
boy whose job was to help the
five-year-olds across the street
and then when school ended she would
leave on her own wander around the
neighborhood with her friends and go
home by six o'clock when she was hungry
right that was what childhood was like
for almost all humans for almost all of
our history children just went off they
ran around they played with each other
and then they came home
and by the time lenoir became a parent
she was living in queens in the 90s
by then
children never played outside except
without without adults looking after
them
you were expected to walk your child to
school and wait and make sure the child
walked through the door and you were
expected to be there to pick them up
like a package at the end of the day by
only 10 of american children
ever played outside their home without
adult supervision and i think if i
remember rightly even the ones that did
the average was something like 10
minutes a week right so basically
nothing right childhood began to happen
entirely behind closed doors which was
unprecedented in human history never
been done
and there's lots of evidence if you look
at the component parts of that that that
damages attention so let's look i go
through lots of them but let's look at a
really no sherlock one
um evidence is very clear children who
exercise and run around can focus much
better than children who don't in fact
the single one of the single best
treatments for children with attention
problems is to let them go and run
around right and yet we have physically
prevented children from running around
and the reason lenoir is one of the
heroes of the book and a completely
amazing human being
is lenore realized look if you face that
problem and you're a parent
you can't be the only parent sending
your child out that you just seem like a
mad person and the child gets frightened
so she set up she runs it already
existed before her actually but she she
began to run an amazing organization i
really recommend everyone looks up
called let grow.org which is about
persuading entire communities entire
schools entire groups of parents to
restore childhood let our children grow
and i caught andra i can't tell you how
moving it was to go and look at these
programs i'll give you an example
i went to a woodland or to their program
in long island and we went to two
schools we went to a place called
roanoke elementary
and we met a group of nine-year-olds and
then we went to a kind of um and that
was in quite poor neighbor then we went
to a kind of fancier neighborhood and we
spoke to teenagers and i'll give you an
example of one of the kids
there was this boy there he was a 14
year old boy
and he was a big strapping strong 14
and until this program had begun nine
months before his parents had never let
him out of his house unsupervised never
they didn't let him go over a run round
the block right
and and i'll never forget the phrase he
used he said they wouldn't let me out
because they were worried about the
phrase he used was all these kidnappings
now this is a part of long island where
the french bakery is across the street
from the olive oil
statistically the odds of something like
that happening to a kid so low and i
gotta say man like i i see even the
cartoon programming that our kids are
exposed to and it's like stranger
dangers like i know it's like like it
makes it seem like the world is filled
with deadly threats and i'm just like
this is not great training this young
man had had a level of fear that would
have been appropriate if he had lived in
medellin at the height of pablo
escobar's terror right when in fact his
chances of being kidnapped are his
chances of being hit by lightning are
three times greater than his chance of
being kidnapped
but then this program began
and he began to play outdoors with his
friends and eventually what happened is
they went to the woods
and they built a fort together and they
left their phones at home and they went
to this fort and they talked and they
played and they ran around and this boy
describing this with his friends
it was like watching someone come to
life and after he left lenoir said you
know think about
all of human history for almost all of
human history people had to go out they
had to hunt they had to seek they had to
build and then in one generation we took
all of that away from children and that
boy the minute he was set free went with
his friends into the woods and built a
fort and there is something deep in
human nature children want to roam and
the only place where our children get to
roam around and get to be free is in
video games i went to this place called
um restart washington which is um
the first ever internet rehab center in
the world it's outside spokane in
washington i remember when i
when i arrived there
it's like a clearing in the woods
the first thing i did absolutely
instinctively when i arrived was look at
my phone and feel really irritated i
couldn't get any reception and i was
like oh wait you're in the right place
the rehab center for internet addiction
um but i remember i spent a lot of time
there
speaking to these young men and they get
all kinds of people there but they
disproportionately get young men who
become obsessed with multiplayer online
role-playing games like when i was there
it was world of warcraft but i'm
guessing now it would be fortnite
and it was so interesting talking to
these young men some of them also became
assessed with porn and it it was so
interesting because i i realized that
afterwards talking to dr cash who runs
the clinic
that they're getting something out of
these games and dr cash said to me gotta
ask yourself what they're getting
they're getting the things they used to
get from the culture but they no longer
get
they're getting a sense that someone
sees them
they're getting a sense that they're
physically roaming around and exploring
and they're getting a sense they're good
at something a big part of the book is i
talk about we have a school system that
makes people feel incompetent right that
is trains them for meaningless tests
which makes ruins your attention
and makes in particular boys feel really
incompetent like they're not good at
anything and so how can we be surprised
how kids are obsessed with playing video
games if the only way they get to roam
around and it's a world of achievement
and status and relationships uh and
identity and then you know the real
world
is not providing those things in the
same way
exactly i think you put it better than i
could i think that's exactly true
and so there are all sorts of things i
think we need if we're gonna have a
movement to rebuild attention there are
many goals we could have and i i propose
you know about
15 possible ones we could think of but
for me the top of the list would be ban
this business model surveillance
capitalism restore childhood every
school should have a let grow program
and we need to really deeply restore
childhood and i think again these things
cut across left and right
um you know i think i've written the
only books that have ever been praised
by uh noam chomsky hillary clinton and
tucker carlson um and the third i would
say is move to a four-day week because i
went yes we love the four-day work week
there's a big overlap between our
interests here but it was fascinating
because i went to a place in australia
this is another person who'd be great
for your podcast the guy who did this oh
sorry not in australia in new zealand or
people in australia will be very angry
at new zealanders sorry it's like when
you confuse canadians for americans i
went to new zealand
um to in to see an incredible experiment
that'd been done in this there was a guy
called andrew barnes who'd had an
experience of just extremely overworking
all throughout his 20s and 30s being
exhausted he'd done that in britain he
left and went and became very successful
in new zealand and australia and then he
was running a very successful business
called perpetual guardian that um runs
wills and trusts
and he just wondered if he he read a
load of research that showed that the
average worker only focuses on their
work for about two hours a day and the
rest of the time they're just sort of
not in in the zone right and he thought
one of the reasons might be that they're
exhausted people are chronically
overworking in our culture so he decided
to do an experiment he just announced he
was moving his entire company
from a five day week to a four day week
for the same amount of money when he
announced it his head of hr literally
fell over
but they did it and i went and
interviewed everyone who worked in their
offices in a town in rotorua which is in
new zealand um it's a very nice town but
it smells weirdly of farts because it's
got they've got something she would
sulfur anyway very nice place otherwise
and um
and it was fascinating so what they had
discovered and this was monitored by
academics at the
um the business school in auckland
is they achieved more in four days than
they did in five and this has happened
in so many places where they've done
experiments with four day weeks
and at first when i learned that it felt
almost too good to be true
but then there was a i went to interview
professor jeffrey pfeffer in stanford
who's an expert on organizational
behavior and he said to me look if you
want to understand why it works it's not
complicated ask any sports fan
do you want your team to walk onto the
pitch exhausted burned out
or do you want them to walk on the pitch
refreshed renewed having rested having
slept well
it's not a difficult choice right so i
would argue although there's many other
potential things we could fight for and
i can talk about loads of other big
social reforms that we could do and of
course i talk about lots of individual
things people can do
i think if we fought for those three
things
first thing i think those three things
appeal to pretty much everyone it'd be
an odd person who didn't find those
things appealing
secondly i think in the medium term they
are achievable
and thirdly i think they'll begin to
give us the space to get our focus back
where we could then begin to look at
some of the other causes uh some of the
other 12 causes that i'm talking about
does that ring true to you andrew
i enthusiastically endorse
your top three
change the business model of these tech
companies
let's give kids their childhood back
and
uh let's go to a four-day work week
amen
and
so
so i i'm completely on board the forward
party is completely on board with those
goals they'll be very popular uh and i
am completely on board with everyone
picking up your book because it's an
important book i hope it spurs a
revolution
stolen focus why you can't pay attention
and how you can think more deeply
there's so much wisdom in this book
johan there's a lot of humanity
there there you know you're very
thorough so it's got all of the backup
in terms of the experts and the science
um but but there's
a heart behind it um and i think what
what you're articulating really is that
you know we're losing our sense of self
um we have to take it back
and you're a champion of humanity for
this
i hope this book is a
worldwide bestseller everyone listening
to this should buy the book
uh and then
equally importantly let's do something
about it let's
take back our own minds uh and help
accomplish some of these goals that
johan's setting out really i'm i'm so
thrilled to be having this conversation
with you
uh and
one other thing is that i feel like
you're such a fount that we could do
this again and just talk about a totally
different set of things and you're
already working on
like other things you've got like an
incredibly
uh prolific mind my friend um but yeah
i'm a thousand percent on board with
those three goals oh thanks andrew
you're doing such important work and
you're in the book because i really
admire the work you're doing and um i
meant to say my publishers tase me if i
don't say this and anyone people can
listen for free on the website to
interviews with loads of the experts
with all the experts we've talked about
if they go to stolenfocusbook.com and
they can also see there where to get the
audio book the ebook or the physical
book you're meant to say you can buy it
in all good book shops but i also want
to say you can buy in shitty book shops
as well it's not like there's not like a
bar where like only the good book stops
stock it but um yeah and yeah i got in
trouble at the end of a
a um
interview a while back because at the
end of it they said to me you know
what's your social media they said
what's your they said what's your
twitter and i said it even though i
don't look at it very much my assistant
does i tell my sister what to do what to
tweet uh they said what's your facebook
what's your instagram and then they said
to me what's your snapchat and i said i
am a 43 year old man the only 43 year
old men on snapchat are certainly
pedophiles right like why are they there
what's going on and i said the um the
you know that tv show to catch a
predator i said the next season of to
catch a predator should literally be
they go up to adult men in the street
and say what is your snapchat handle and
if they have an answer just immediately
arrest them right anyway the guy who was
interviewing me didn't laugh i later
looked him up and he's he's older than
40 and has a very substantial snapchat
presence and i was like oh dear i've
accidentally called him a pedophile i'm
glad i got through this interview with
her absolutely horribly insulting you
because i'm a big fan of yours so hooray
uh you made it
stolenfocusbook.com uh sounds like an
awesome resource and a lot of my fans
love audiobooks and audio clips so go to
stolenfocusbook.com
you can hear the interviews that johan
conducted
for this book or just buy the book the
old-fashioned way
uh but i'm i'm a huge admirer of this
man and his work and we should support
him in any way we can buying a book's
the least we can do am i right people
i'm right
brilliant
[Music]
you